de entrada pudimos conversar con varios
diputados aquí en la asamblea nacional
cuando salían de presenciar ese anuncio
de la primera ministra Elizabeth donne
de forzar esta la implementación de esta
ley de esta reforma de pensiones aquí en
Francia Ellos nos expresaban que se
sentían ofendidos que esto es un
atentado contra la democracia incluso
cuando esa posibilidad que utilizó el
gobierno Hoy está contemplada y
protegida por la ley decían que esto
confirma el carácter impopular del
gobierno del presidente Emmanuel macron
algo que de ser así sería un Secreto a
voces y que reconocía el propio
presidente Emmanuel macron en la jornada
de su cuando se declaró ganador en la
elección de abril de 2022 Cuando decía
que sabía que las personas no habían
votado por él o muchas personas no
habían votado por él sino contra Marín
lepén el propio Emanuel macrón lamentaba
haber tenido que recurrir al cuarenta y
nueve tres haber decidido eso en el
consejo de ministros decía que
interés político era ir al voto pero que
no pudo concertarse una mayoría los
sindicatos han anunciado que continuarán
en pie de lucha contra esta reforma de
pensiones el líder de la serie t la
central la confederación general del
trabajo Philip Martínez decía que el
gobierno debe encontrar una respuesta
que se corresponda con su desdén hacia
el pueblo y esta misma noche Esa esa
organización intersindical se reunirá
para decidir Cuál será la hoja de ruta a
partir de mañana y Luis Miguel en el
marco de la hoja de ruta que ahora se
puede abrir pero dentro de las
instituciones en la asamblea nacional
como decíamos la única forma que tendría
la oposición de tumbar esta reforma
sería tumbando al gobierno con una
moción de censura que se sabe de
posibles propuestas de emociones de
censura hasta el momento
de entrada incluso antes de anunciarse
El 49 el uso del 49.3 varios partidos la
Francia en sumisa reagrupación nacional
el grupo minoritario habían ya
configurado tenían listas esas mociones
de censura son iniciativas que son
anunciadas hoy han estado siendo
anunciadas ya desde esta tarde y hasta
hasta de entrada la noche van a ser
presentadas este mismo viernes y solo
una de ellas la que sea respaldada por
una mayor cantidad de diputados será
votada en la asamblea nacional podría
ser el mismo lunes o a inicios de la
semana próxima Sí esa moción de censura
es aprobada aprobada como lo mencionabas
esto obligaría a Elizabeth a presentar
su dimisión sería un escenario de
presión que si es lo suficientemente
fuerte podría también implicar que el
presidente Emmanuel macron retirara la
reforma de pensiones ha sucedido en el
pasado Ya Aunque en este caso
parece Más bien impro y bueno si es
rechazada esta moción de censura por
ejemplo la
presidenta o la diputada del grupo de
reagrupación nacional decía que va a
votar cualquier moción de censura venga
de donde venga y lo contrario el
presidente del partido de los
republicanos decía que no va a agregar
más caos al caos votando por una por una
moción de censura sabemos que en el
pasado no han podido prosperar esas
iniciativas parlamentarias precisamente
porque los republicanos se han opuesto
de manera que si la moción de censura es
rechazada habría todavía una posibilidad
por ejemplo se podría acudir al consejo
constitucional se podía presentar un
recurso allí para ganar tiempo impedir
la implementación de la Reforma de
pensiones a partir de septiembre y esto
permitiría también la implementación de
un RIP un referendo de iniciativa
popular que si se cumple una serie de
condiciones apoyo dentro del senado
apoyo dentro de la asamblea y cuatro
coma siete millones de firmas podría
proponer al presidente de la república
que retire esa reforma de pensiones
Estas son las posibilidades que tenemos
hasta el momento pero estamos hablando
de política ficción porque apenas acaba
de aprobarse aquí en la asamblea
nacional por la fuerza esa reforma de
pensiones y Luis Miguel déjeme que le
haga Una última pregunta Precisamente en
relación a lo que usted decía que los
republicanos ya han anunciado que no van
a apoyar la moción de censura por lo que
podríamos decir que Manuel macron Ha
logrado un poco lo que buscaba con este
49.3 no porque precisamente tenía
incertidumbre ante lo que podrían votar
sus aliados republicanos a la reforma de
las pensiones pero contaba con que no
iban a apoyar la moción de censura no
podríamos decir
Lamentablemente a muchos intereses en
juego sabemos que si se aprobara esta
moción de censura una de las
posibilidades rosa es que el propio
Emanuel macron disuelva la asamblea de
manera que tendríamos que acudir a
elecciones legislativas y en las
encuestas indican que uno de los
partidos que perdería escaños aquí en la
cámara baja del parlamento sería
precisamente los republicanos de manera
que como no les conviene Pues adoptan
esta posición como tú lo apuntabas